gentlemen how are you both doing good
well look at that look at those things
no this guy i've known this guy forever
and and it we were just talking about
you the other day i was i was
referencing you the other day hold up
your fingernails real quick uh they're
not painted right now actually
okay anyway i'll shut up now sorry
uh i that was not the way i thought this
interview was going to get started
i'll just say that uh i want to start
with um how much i love this movie
seriously you guys did such a phenomenal
job this movie is so good um
at what point during the making of this
film did you both realize that you were
part of something special uh
for me
the other day two days ago when the
movie opened in venice and people
cheered up and
uploaded for many minutes i thought okay
so it seems like it's a good movie but
you're never sure what you've done of
course the first time i saw it i thought
it was a great movie but
it's when you screen it and the reaction
of the audience that really ends
the movie itself and you realize what it
is you're tainted by your experience of
doing the movie you know you've you've
had these friendships now you have these
loyalties you have these you want it to
be you have this
thing inside you that wants it to be
great you want to need to win you want
you know what i'm saying you want the
book to win you want the
the final manifestation like finally
after so we're technologically so
advanced now we're able to do things
that we won't be able to do or denise
and you know so you're this chi you
champion it but until you see you watch
other people see it and react to it i
took a guy when i saw his screening the
first time a big dune fan and i asked
him to come to the screening and there
was a pause after the screening and he's
48 year old 48 years old and you know a
mature apparently a mature adult and he
started screaming at the top of his
lungs that was a great reaction you know
that's the reaction that you want
uh with how the world is currently do
you think dune is more relevant now than
when it was first published in 65
i think in many things yes ecologically
speaking
environmentally speaking yes the the
freyman steel guard the the the role i
play the character i play is very aware
of the
destruction of the planet of his planet
and he wants to take good care of that
and try to
maneuver
through the
very hard landscape in order to survive
and that landscape itself it's a warning
signal for all of us because it's not
it's not
that far
from things that we are watching or
experiencing unfortunately so yes it's
only that is very very uh
i mean
right on time
uh my last question for both of you uh
um i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of any movie
especially a film like this for each of
you can you share maybe what people
might be surprised to learn about the
making of dune
well we greg frazier and i did a book in
tonya la pointe la pointe this lapuant
um who produced it she she did it's a
it's three books in one but greg and i
did one of those books and it's his
behind-the-scenes photography and my
writing which is a good in into you know
how much fun we had you know the kind of
env environmental influence that that
was felt when we were in jordan when we
were in budapest when we were in you
know the sets the how massive and
practical the sets were
so you know the experience is always a
little different than the final product
this final product is
an amazing result
but the experience was was very intimate
on on this show very fun and very
intimate
you want to add anything javier
no exactly that he was he was uh
i'm saying that sometimes i felt i was
doing a very small independent movie by
the way denis was taking care of it
taking care of the performances and the
the way he would
help us to try different things without
the pressure of being such a big scope
again congrats i'm gonna get kicked out
of the room have a fantastic day thank
you so much thank you